it's on to South Carolina where CBS News
will co-host the democratic debate in
Charleston next week is you may have
heard I'll be one of the moderators
along with Norah O'Donnell we've been
talking to voters across the country to
find out what they want to ask the
candidates their questions covered a
whole range everything from immigration
to climate change to health care my name
is Gabriella fine and I'm from Silver
Spring Maryland when I was 10 years old
I was diagnosed with type 1 diabetes
people with type 1 diabetes need insulin
to survive my question is how would you
prevent pharmaceutical companies from
driving up the cost of life-saving drugs
one of my friends from home their
parents are being deported in two years
because of Trump's immigration policies
I was wondering what you candidates can
do to help them and undo the past I'm a
23 year old paralegal for Minnesota
looking to become a civil rights
attorney today more than 2 million
Americans sit behind bars in our
nation's correctional facilities the
overwhelmingly disproportionate number
of whom are people of color and those
with mental illness as president what do
you plan to do to bring more attention
to this issue and actually solve it
my name is Silvia McCown I volunteer at
a food pantry here in Flint Michigan
where I meet a lot of people who are
working full time at minimum wage jobs
but still can't seek to make ends meet
my question to the candidates is what
can you do to provide additional help
for these people hi my name is gali
Gordon my great-grandparents fled the
Russian Empire and arrived in the United
States before World War one were very
concerned with the recent rising tide in
hatred and anti-semitism that has turned
deadly what is your plan to combat this
rising hatred
as a mother of two teenagers who are
soon to go to college my question for
the candidates is how do you address the
rising cost and quality of education and
the debt burden associated with it how
will you protect the LGBTQ community
through actions and policies
specifically ones that protect trans
women of color what is your plan to fund
and combat the mental health and
addiction crisis in America I want to
know what you as a candidate are gonna
do about climate change or a real action
you're gonna take
hi I'm Tyler and I'm Maura and our
four-year-old son has special needs
resulting from meningitis as an infant
in 1975 Congress passed the individuals
with Disabilities Education Act
mandating that all students with
disabilities be provided a free and
appropriate education however since then
it has never been fully funded and we
would like to know what you'll do to
ensure adequate funding for students
like our son in all public school
students I was not able to immediately
attend medical school me too my legal
status as an undocumented immigrant my
question to the candidates is how would
you galvanize Congress so that they can
pass relief and supportive legislation
for refugees and undocumented immigrants
I became an advocate for people
experiencing homelessness 20 years ago
when my brother first became homeless
due to mental illness every night over
1/2 million people are without a home I
want to know what you're gonna do to
address this crisis immediately
partnering with state and local
government
the u.s. is predicted to have a shortage
of 120,000 doctors by 2030
how do we prepare to care for our
citizens in the coming future I switched
from registered Democrat to independent
due to the DNC failures on the current
platform if you were the nominee how is
the de-facto leader the Democratic Party
would you do damage control and woo back
people like myself and young people we
face a difficult economic future
student debt is astronomical
homeownership has become inaccessible in
many places and climate change will
place and increasing costs in our
communities my question is what will you
do to ensure young people see themselves
thriving in the future of this country
[Music]
those are all really good wow so many
good questions and you know it's a
two-hour debate of course no matter what
you do there will be somebody that says
why didn't you ask why didn't you ask
gave us a lot of really great arguments
the scale and the scope of the problems
that this country faces shows you that
you can't even get to all of mahjongg I
know shout again to Ileana men she
strikes again her pieces are always so
good I say this all the time it's hard
to do a piece with no track make it look
good Bravo Ileana tune in on Tuesday for
the Democratic presidential debate in
Charleston South Carolina as you've
heard hosted by CBS News Nora Donnell
and I will be joined will be moderating
and we'll be joined by first-class team
of our colleagues Margaret Brennan major
Garrett and Bill Whitaker of 60 minutes
in the questioning the Congressional
Black Caucus Institute is a co-host and
Twitter is a partner you can see the
debate on Tuesday at 8 p.m. Eastern 7
central right here on CBS and CBS n I'm
glad starting at eight not nine yes the
selfish reason and if you would like to
include a question for the candidates
you can submit it on twitter by using
the hashtag dem debate